comp julie please go ahead and share
your screen
julie is a phd student at the university
of washington
working on program synthesis and
related topics and julie's talk today is
going to be on the synthesis of
functional reactive programs
hi thank you go ahead yeah uh quick
again my check you can see my slides
where uh we're all set up
yes everything looks good thank you
excellent all right hi well um
yeah thank you for the invitation uh my
name is julie newcomb i'm
one of ross's students here at the
university of washington and i
am here to just um quickly introduce you
some ongoing work that we're doing
synthesizing functional reactive
programs so functional reactive
programming or frp
is functional programming that takes
streams of asynchronous events as inputs
and some of the application domains
where this is used includes
internet of things programming ar and vr
web programming games
all those sorts of things
excellent okay so it won't surprise this
audience to hear that writing programs
over asynchronous inputs
is a difficult task and it's even more
difficult for end users or people who
are not
professional programmers these users can
miss tricky corner cases
it's difficult for them to anticipate
all the different states their program
can get into over these long
execution times and their these programs
are difficult to debug and to test
so i have an example um use case for you
to think about let's imagine that we
have an
iot controller and a smart home that
operates in
three modes the home can kind of be in
the home mode away mode or
night mode and we calculate this mode uh
using
um the times of sunrise and sunset in
our location
as well as a sensor on the front door
that tracks when the document enters and
leaves so we know
if the home is occupied or not so now
let's imagine that we have a motion
sensor in the kitchen that when this
motion sensor goes off we want the
kitchen light to turn on but when we're
operating in night mode we want it to be
like kind of a soft orange light
otherwise we should be a bright white
light
so i have here an implementation of that
program in the frp language
rx and i've drawn it as a graph so we
don't have to parse
too much syntax so we have our three
inputs to the programs
we have the kitchen motion sensor we
have the sunrise and sunset times and we
have the sensor on the front door
we have few instances of a map operator
that takes a stream and a first class
function and then returns the
the process stream we have two operators
that combine streams in different ways
we have a merge operator and the um
with latest from operator which you can
think of as kind as a fold
in a functional programming sense um so
this program has a bug uh in the
interest of time i'll ask you to just
believe me that it has a bug but um the
point that i want to get across is that
these programs really can't be tricky to
get right
but these programs are also um very
concise and expressive
uh you can see this program has just
five operators for what we're trying to
do
and so because these programs are so
small and expressive they're very
attractive target for synthesis
so our idea was that users often have a
clear idea of the behavior of their
program in kind of a normal case a kind
of a happy path case
but they will miss corner cases and they
may not have even thought about
exactly what they want their program to
do in certain inputs that they haven't
considered
so we proposed this interactive tool
where the user begins with a partial
specification
and the tool would synthesize multiple
candidate reductions i'm sorry
multiple candidate programs and that's
the user to disambiguate
and then we go through some iterations
the user can kind of
explore the space of potential programs
and then they converge on the one that
they really wanted
so what this means is that to arrive at
the program that we ultimately want
we're going to have to synthesize not
just one but many programs throughout
this loop
so we need a good efficient synthesis
algorithm
so it seems natural to models stream
events as a list
so how easy would it be for us to
synthesize functional programs that take
lists as inputs
so we looked at two recent tools called
decoder and neo
that synthesize programs in a functional
list manipulation dsl
i have an example program in that dsl
that i grabbed from the
deep coder paper to give you a flavor um
i think it's pretty much what you'd what
you'd expect to see so we put together a
tool that synthesized programs in this
dsl that we built on top of the cgs
synthesizer in rosette
and we replicated their same means as
randomly generating benchmarks so we can
compare them with these tools
and you can see that we were able to
solve slightly more benchmarks than new
and although our times are worse than
both tools we're kind of roughly the
same performance neighborhood
this was a pretty vanilla implementation
and we think if we'd spend some time
tuning it we could do better but this
was enough to convince us that this is a
feasible approach for synthesizing list
programs
so now that we we believe that we can do
that we need some way to reduce
functional reactive programs to
functional programs over lists
so we came up with two ways of modeling
event streams as a list of values and
you can
look at this little chart here on the
left and think of it as the x-axis
time and at the time one we had some
event that had a value three and at the
point two we had some
event that had a value two and so on and
then i have two different ways of
representing um those events occurring
in time so
we have what i'm calling a clock-based
uh representation which is kind of a
sparse representation
where each element in the list
represents a time step or kind of a tick
of the clock
and then we have this special no event
value that represents the time step at
which nothing happened
and then we have an event-based
reduction where we have lists of pairs
where each pair
is a time step and a value of the event
that occurred at that time step
so the event-based model initially
seemed more promising to us it seemed to
give us a lot more flexibility
in the length of time that our pen plus
can cover and it makes us it makes it
easier to depict um the series of events
where perhaps
you know some events occur very close
together and then there's a long
interval and then another event occurs
and so on
um but the clock-based model when we
started sort of playing
uh was synthesizing these programs the
clock-based model was so
dramatically faster than synthesized
that we didn't even bother running
formal experiments it just
was that much more performant um so i'm
going to
talk to you a few reasons why that is uh
so first of all
this seems obvious but the clock-based
model uses half the number of integers
than the event-based model and
that has an appreciable effect on
solving times um the clock-based model
leverages the list data structure to
hold the sequence of the events so we
don't have to explicitly manage it using
timestamps
and then if you think of a program that
has multiple inputs the clock based
model can
walk over them in steps since these the
streams are on this clock
and we know when events happen at the
same time
whereas in the event-based model we have
to do a lot of bookkeeping over our
multiple inputs so for example if we
merge two input streams we basically
have to sort those events
based on their time step and that's just
more extra you know algorithmic overhead
that gets passed on to the solver
um so you may feel that the uh
this clock-based model feels quite
restrictive if we have a list of fixed
size
um we're kind of forcing ourselves to
you know take these asynchronous inputs
and force them to be on a clock which is
not really what we were trying to do
uh the example i gave you before was a
program that ran over a 24-hour cycle
um but we kind of loosen our semantics a
little bit and think about
the um the clock or the time steps as
just
representing the point at which the next
interesting thing happens uh to our
system and not that it's actually
has anything to do that correspond with
wall clock time and um
if we kind of make that that semantic
loosening in our minds it's actually
um it actually works out surprisingly
well
so um i will wrap up here
as i said this is ongoing work and i'd
be happy to take any questions but i
also want to put the call out to this
audience um we
are actively looking for more benchmarks
or more interesting problem domains if
anyone has any suggestions um i would i
would love to hear about them either
now or offline and and i will i'll eat
the floor
thank you thank you julie
um are there any questions
or radu has a question go ahead i don't
have a question it's just a comment uh
yeah so for example especially if you if
you go from
deterministic to to non-deterministic
uh stream processing functions
it is known that you have problems so
you don't have
unique solutions you have the brokerman
anomaly and the merge
firmware anomalies and uh by introducing
times of
introducing clock is the way to to solve
them so
this might be one reason why it's so
much better you know when you have
clocks
than than working in an asynchronous
okay
okay this sounds like uh um
something i should i should look up then
um
so it's called the carman anomaly and
the fair merger normally but they they
are typically appear when you are in a
in a relational setting you know when
when you
you know and it's exactly the fair merge
problem so how do you merge two streams
if you don't have
time timing information now you have
amps that something about the
the time you know but uh you know it's
kind of
it's not so and that's that's why maybe
the fact your time
explicit time is much better and it
turns out i mean
look people try to to create
asynchronous
circuits for a long time they never yeah
yeah they still have clock
so and there is also this wall
synchronization for for
you know distributed systems which is
also this wall is exactly like
what you were saying is when you put the
when the interesting stuff happens
right yeah yeah yeah i would not be at
all surprised if we are um reinventing
the wheel a little bit here but
yeah you're not reinventing it that's
why it works so much better
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
think the the key insight for us is that
it doesn't really matter the
interval between the events but knowing
when events occur at the same time was
crucial
yeah exactly yeah yeah so yeah thank you
i hope so
i'll just add a quick comment that i'm
not sure that that is the
thing behind it because even though
there is a clock the clock is really
there just to order
the events the way they arrive so i'd
say it is fully asynchronous that way
and even in the case of the timestamp
you can just think of a sort of giving
an ordering number to the events and i i
yeah but that's the important thing you
need to know the order so especially
when you do the fair merge you know
if you don't know the order then it's
it's uh and this is what
fair wi-fi merge anomaly happens if you
have several streams
and you have no information about their
relative ordering
you don't know how to do the merge you
know and uh something to look into thank
you
all right uh with that i think we can
bring the session to a close thank you
all and
and thanks to the audience for staying
with us for an extra 25 minutes
um and we'll see you all next week um
just a sneak peek is next week we'll go
back to a tutorial
and this one will be a tutorial on
machine learning um
because we're seeing more and more use
of machine learning and synthesis
and so uh we hope you'll all find that
useful all right
thank you